today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so yesterday was day one of the
republican national convention
and i've been struggling since it ended
at 11 pm eastern last night
to figure out really how to cover it or
even talk about it
and when people do in public
what many of last night's republican
speakers did at the rnc
it would lead to a and 911 a 72-hour
psych hold i mean that's how outrageous
what we saw last night was
and in thinking how to cover it it's
sort of like do i
include a ton of clips do i include just
a few do i cover
every speaker or just the highlights do
i cover the broad strokes of what the
convention is doing
versus the minutia of what each speaker
is saying and
um i don't really know the answer so
i'll just give you a few of my thoughts
for today and then we'll see tomorrow
how we cover it
the theme yesterday was attack joe biden
but a little more specifically it was
rich people
and trust fund kids telling us that
democrats are being mean to capitalism
and that if joe biden gets elected
there's going to be some kind of a
marxist revolution in this country
and all of a sudden the united states
will be a communist
dystopia and on top of this
yesterday was riddled with identity
politics
now it was riddled with the same
identity politics that republicans claim
to be against one of my takeaways
from watching yesterday's rnc is i'm not
crowbaring
being hispanic into nearly enough
conversations
if i yesterday every speaker
who could justify being anything other
than
a white person mentioned it multiple
times don jr's girlfriend kimberly
guilfoyle reminding us multiple times
that she's hispanic
nikki haley that she's i believe native
american
tim scott that he's black vernon jones
that he's black
i thought they were against identity
politics but i guess maybe
they're only against it when it's
democrats but clearly if i am to take a
lesson from republicans and why would i
but if i were to
in any opportunity that i have i should
be mentioning
by the way i'm hispanic did you know
that um
when i thought about yesterday's
presentations in total
i thought back to that bizarre time
where in 2012
at the rnc clint eastwood spoke to a
chair
and that was nothing as embarrassing and
humiliating
as that was for clint eastwood whether
he recognized it or not and i think he's
since said he regrets it that was
nothing
eight years ago compared to yesterday's
first day of the republican national
convention
it was really one of the most deeply
dystopian events
and what made it more dystopian was the
degree to which republican voters loved
it i was looking on twitter i was
looking in some of the uh
recesses and cesspools of the pro-trump
internet and people were just
enamored with what they saw so let's
look at
some clips again i've been debating how
to cover this i think for today i'm
gonna do one
basically one wrap-up clip and then
we'll do separate clips for specific
stories as needed
so each day we'll have sort of like the
main
wrap-up and of course i'm not going to
be able to get to everything if you
don't like this way of covering it
just let me know and i'll look at look
at something else it's hours and hours
of stuff so it's very difficult to get
to all of it now two of the most
pyongyang
north korea-like propaganda speeches
came
from donald trump's son don jr and don
junior's girlfriend
former fox news hostess kimberly
guilfoyle recently recovered of course
from coronavirus now i'm going to start
with kimberly guilfoyle
because kimberly guilfoyle's speech was
the absolutely most outrageous
thing not just at last night's
republican national convention
but really at any ra republican national
convention that i've covered or watched
just screaming uncontrollably seemed
like a crazy person and i'm not using
that pejoratively she
she seemed out of it she seemed ill
take a look at this first clip ladies
and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
and then just go yeah then just going
fully
fascistic this is the language of
dictators
who just project onto others what they
actually want to do
take a look at this they want to destroy
this country and everything that we have
fought for
and hold dear they want to steal your
liberty
your freedom they want to control what
you see and think
and believe so that they can control how
you live they want to enslave you to the
weak
dependent liberal victim ideology to the
point
that you will not recognize this country
or yourself
so this was outrageous i mean it was
you know it i you could analyze it
five or six different ways um it
was it mania was it delusional
was it that she chose to play a
character and the character was bonkers
i i just don't know and then she was
sort of
almost matched in a sort of different
tone in tenor
by donald trump jr her
partner um in full propaganda mode
essentially saying embrace the dear
leader i mean the shades of north korean
propaganda
yesterday couldn't be missed take a look
at don jr here
imagine the life you want to have one
with a great job
a beautiful home a perfect family you
can have it
imagine the country you want to live in
one with true
equal opportunity where hard work pays
off and justice is served with
compassion and without partiality
you can have it imagine a world where
the evils of communism and radical
islamic terrorism
are not given a chance to spread where
heroes are celebrated and the good guys
win
you can have it that is the life
that is the country that is the world
that donald trump and the republican
party are after
and yes you can have it
because unlike joe biden and the radical
left democrats
our party is open to everyone
everything you want can be given to you
by donald trump and donald trump only
but
notice it's not going to happen in four
years it's going to take
trump eight years to give you everything
nobody else can do it
and trump also couldn't do it in four
years which is why he needs another four
to give you all of these things
any time that you hear this one man can
give you everything stuff and we heard
it in 2016 when trump would say
only i can fix it that's an
authoritarian red flag
and likewise the projection
was just off the wall kimberly guilfoyle
projecting onto joe biden the
authoritarianism
which is actually the hallmark of donald
trump
and then they brought out a
cuban-american named
maximo alvarez and as i've mentioned
before on the program
as a hispanic american myself remember
if the rnc has taught me anything it's i
need to constantly talk about how i'm
hispanic
the only latin american group in the
united states that has any significant
amount of conservatism is cuban
americans
all other latino groups are
overwhelmingly liberal
in the united states they brought out a
cuban-american maximo alvarez who
equated joe biden
to fidel castro if you can imagine take
a look speaking to you today because
i have seen people like this before i've
seen movements like this before
i've seen ideas like this before
and i am here to tell you we cannot let
them
take over our country i heard the
promises of fidel castro
and i can never forget all those who
grew up around me
who looked like me who suffered
and starved and died because they
believe those empty promises
now anybody who has any connection to
reality
would know that there is no similarity
between center left joe biden who's been
pulled
a little bit further to the left over
the last three months there's nothing
linking him to fidel castro
nor to venezuelan leaders hugo chavez or
nicolas maduro but the constant imagery
yesterday linking
biden to venezuela linking biden to cuba
to socialism to marxism
meanwhile the progressive left is
disappointed that biden
isn't really that progressive i mean
it's just a fantasy world
that this convention was based on now i
don't want to give the next two people
too much attention because it's
borderline criminal that they're even
part of the republican national
convention
but the mccloskeys this is the couple
from st louis who brandished firearms at
black
lives matter protesters they were
invited to speak
th this is a couple their lawyers who
are known
only for pointing long guns or i think
it was one long gun and a handgun
at protesters in st louis a few weeks
ago
they spoke i'm only going to give you
five seconds of them
that they don't i'm not i'm just
refusing to give you more
here is i believe it's patricia
mccloskey the wife
saying that joe biden wants to end the
suburbs
to abolish the suburbs all together by
ending
single-family home zoning it's really an
indictment
of everything that these people
were even speakers at the convention and
then
finishing out the joe biden will abolish
stuff
phase of our review here is natalie harp
claiming that joe biden would
essentially abolish doctors people
wouldn't be able to have doctors anymore
if joe biden were president
god forbid what the next four years
would look like
for in joe biden's america china would
control our drug production
we'd be one step closer to
government-run health care
we wouldn't just be unable to keep our
doctors we'd be lucky if we could see
any doctor
we would be lucky if we could see any
doctor
under joe biden says natalie harp now
there were many more speakers quite
frankly i i don't think i can tolerate
too much more
but the themes were claimed that there
was no policy discussed at the dnc
and then don't talk about any policy
disparage the dnc
as being just about criticizing trump
but then spend the entire time merely
criticizing joe biden
as a marxist and a communist and i'm
truly questioning
number one the future of this country if
60 million people see this and then vote
for it in november
and number two whether i'm actually
going to be able to make it through
three more days of this garbage i'm
going to try
but this was truly i mean it's it's this
isn't healthy this is really bad this is
very very bad
and then to top it off here is my
absolute
favorite moment from day one of the rnc
donald trump staged these little
conversations with different
at one point it was with workers at
another point it was with former
hostages the idea was to put trump
in front of people and make him seem
like a relatable normal guy
and at one point one of the workers that
was part of the group that trump was
speaking to
said i'm a custodian at a school trump
doesn't know what a custodian is
it's just the epitome of a
a privilege where anybody who went
to public school or even to private
school and and was just like enmeshed in
what was going on
you would know the custodian cleans the
school it's not like trump maybe thinks
a financial custodian of assets or
something
the worker says i'm a custodian trump
says oh and what do you do as if
you know i'm dropping everything because
this is so crazy take a look at it
how about you i'm a custodian at the
post office as well
what do you do exactly clean up
everybody's mess and everybody's germs
and
all that that that world that profession
will never be out of business you know
that right
just a microcosm of the entire
republican national convention day one
rich people and trust fund babies
claiming to be
all about workers and the middle class
and fear-mongering that joe biden will
make us
marxist while knowing absolutely nothing
about the middle class and workers so
tonight we go on to day two
everything is always scheduled but could
change
tonight it's melania trump secretary of
state mike pompeo senator rand paul
that covington kid nick sandman eric
trump
and tiffany trump i will see you tonight
8 30 p.m eastern time on youtube and
twitch
so uh now that the republican national
convention is underway
which will include the formal
renomination of donald trump as the
republican nominee for president
accepting formally whoa my chair almost
just fell
accepting formally on thursday something
stunning is going on
the republican party is surrendering
to whatever the hell trump wants and
republicans have announced they are not
going to be adopting
any platform at this week's convention
instead they're saying
we support trump now some of you may
know
if you've seen conventions before it's
not only
typical but it's really one of the key
things that is done
at a convention which is that the
candidate is nominated
but platforms for the party are voted on
and established they're updated every
four years the platform
is modified as makes sense four years of
stuff
has happened now what is really
hilarious is that republicans are saying
you know because of the social
distancing stuff because we're doing
everything safely
we're just not going to do any kind of
platform update and we're essentially
pledging allegiance to whatever the hell
donald trump wants now
there's something very interesting and
specific to this year
policy and platforms are a problem
when donald trump is your nominee
because you've had four years
of doing absolutely nothing and in some
cases
supporting ideas that run counter to
much of what the republican party
actually has stood for
on paper so republicans have decided
we're just not going to unveil
a new platform period and hilariously
they're saying that
it's because the event is scaled back
that they're not going to do it the
truth is if they wanted to unveil a new
platform
there's nothing stopping them from doing
it uh it's the speeches that have to be
scaled back or at least the crowds the
audiences
the in-person stuff but a new platform
could be developed it could be unveiled
regardless of the format and instead the
republican party is pledging to quote
enthusiastically support the president's
america first agenda this of course
is extremely unusual and even some
republicans are saying that the party is
essentially
abandoning its values abandoning its
principles in order to support donald
trump and that is indeed exactly what
they are doing i mean the republicans
willing to say that are correct
they've completely abandoned all of
their stated values and they're just
saying whatever trump wants he gets
elected republicans and the republican
party are descending
into the same cultish behavior that
trump's followers
have fallen into and this is typical
of authoritarians around the world we
talked earlier about don jr's speech
where it's trump alone can fix it trump
is the pr you just you just have to
follow and support trump
policy is irrelevant all that matters is
everybody get in line
and support the dear leader and it's
another
step in the direction of
authoritarianism where there is no
tolerance for critical questions
the group leader is always right the way
to know the truth
is to ask the leader what does the
leader think and the other thing
republicans are probably
too dumb or too distracted to realize is
that by not
changing their 2016 platform they are
conceding that trump has accomplished
accomplished nothing and i'll put it a
different way to make it really clear
they claim and trump claims that he is
the most accomplished president in
history they say and trump says about
himself
i've done more in my first term than any
president in history
and yet their plan for the next four
years
is the same as for the last four years
if the plan is the same
you didn't do the things you said you
were going to do
if you succeeded you would want a
different list of things for the next
four years
it's all incoherent and and i'm
obviously trying to apply
logic where there is no logic but this
is fundamentally a cult
that now extends to the republican party
itself of people who are either too
afraid to go against donald trump
or simply don't care as long as they own
the libs and so they're going to scrap
their platform
put aside everything they claim to stand
for and let trump ramble
for four nights in a uh possibly uh
i mean just historically laughable and
humiliating republican national
convention
and important always
he could get another four years if we
don't act to prevent it
he could end up with another four years
make sure you're following me on twitter
at d pacman and make sure you're getting
the daily audio podcast
on whatever is your favorite podcasting
platform the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes blinkist makes sure
that you're getting all of the important
core
insights from each book so it's perfect
for exploring a book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are amy
hickman
and teresha miller thanks to amy and
teresha and also a big thank you to
robert peterson who's today's long time
sustaining member of the day
robert's been a member like many others
almost five years
you can join these great people by
signing up in under a minute at
joinpacman.com and yes
membership does come with access to the
world famous daily
bonus show it's an extra show every day
just for our members here's an
interesting story that has some people
on the left sort of upset or or
certainly at least concerned on august
17th
about eight days ago the democratic
national committee
removed language from a draft platform
a draft document calling for an end to
subsidies
of fossil fuel companies
and the democratic national committee
and joe biden
and senator kamala harris historically
have opposed fossil fuel subsidies
they've said they would end them and it
was in a draft document
and yet eight days ago the call for the
end to these fossil fuel subsidies was
quietly removed
why did it happen it's not completely
clear but there was huge
backlash a lot of climate activists saw
it
as a stab in the back many people
alleged that
look this is joe biden he said he was
going to do one thing and then they
quietly remove it from the document and
now all of a sudden they're no longer
against abolishing fossil fuel
subsidies which cost somewhere between
20 and 650 billion dollars each year
depending on what you include and how
you measure it
and a bunch of people reacted by saying
this exposes the true biden biden
doesn't really want to do the things he
claims he wants to do
on climate or on whatever else and
it's it's sort of biden showing his true
colors now
after the backlash it's been added back
in
and again it has been restated that
joe biden and kamala harris and the dnc
support ending subsidies to fossil fuel
companies
and of course the reaction from many was
and it's not a crazy reaction
joe biden doesn't really support it but
he only got shamed back into it right
now
so you could chalk this up to confusion
you could chalk it up to a
misunderstanding
you could chalk it up to bad faith i
have to tell you it seems
unlikely to me that what happened here
is that they really were trying to just
remove this pledge to end fossil fuel
subsidies and they got caught and they
put it back in
the way the dnc operates is if they want
to back away from some kind of promise
they do it and they come up with flowery
or non-offensive language to
to defend it so i actually think it's
more likely that this was some kind of a
confusion or a misunderstanding but i
think
it's instructive in that it sort of
reinforces something i've been talking
about for a while which is
if joe biden wins we are getting the
ball back
we are not yet putting any points up on
the board to use a sort of football
analogy
and we're going to have to push joe
biden if he's president and we're going
to have to push him
for the entire time that he is president
so i'm not
hugely worried about this for two
reasons number one
um i i actually do think it was probably
some kind of a mistake or
misunderstanding
because this is not how the dnc would
probably do this
also more than likely if they didn't
plan
to end fossil fuel subsidies or even try
to they would just leave it in but then
just not do it and blame republicans
so i just i think that that's probably
not the explanation
but either way are going to have to
as progressive activists hold joe biden
accountable if we want to get things
done and put points on the board if he
indeed becomes president of the united
states
so i don't think this was some kind of
deliberate betrayal by joe biden his
campaign
seems to have been clear the whole time
and by the way i have to tell you
something else on this particular issue
of ending fossil fuel subsidies
it's going to be difficult to do in four
years it's going to be difficult to do
maybe even in eight years
it should be done we should be shifting
subsidies away from fossil fuels and to
renewables but in practice it's going to
be difficult to do it doesn't mean we
shouldn't try but
part of being able to do it is going to
be getting
off of these fuels in the first place
and it is kind of a chicken egg scenario
as we continue to be dependent on fossil
fuels it will be difficult to remove the
subsidies
and if we remove the subsidies it will
be difficult to get off of them because
the prices of fossil fuels will be kept
artificially low
by the subsidies themselves but it's
going to have to be
a sort of step by step by step but the
hot takes
that are saying this is proof of biden
this or this is proof of biden that
um joe biden's climate proposal would be
the most progressive of any president if
biden wins
and either way we are going to have to
hold him
accountable and that will be the mission
of progressive media i hope that's what
i'm anticipating my job to be
for the next four or eight years if joe
biden succeeds at removing donald trump
in november
this is a super interesting peek behind
the curtain there are now multiple
reports out
that privately donald trump jr believes
that donald trump is going to lose in
november
and lose badly and fascinatingly don jr
reportedly believes
that not only donald trump but don jr
and maybe other members of the family
are going to be indicted and prosecuted
if donald trump loses
loses in november this is so interesting
in terms of what it says about their
realization
about what's going on despite always
claiming everything is great so the new
york times has an interesting piece
about this where
they quote a prominent conservative
activist who was interviewed on the
condition of anonymity
who told the new york times that don jr
thinks they're going to lose in november
and that when they lose they're going to
get quote really hurt
meaning that federal prosecutions of not
just donald trump
but of his family and political allies
may be an inevitability
and according to the same conservative
activists don jr believes that a biden
administration will not
peacefully transition but they will
instead
shoot the prisoners was the term that
don jr used
although that particular piece was later
denied
by andy serabian who's another
republican operative
so there's a few different things here
first let's deal with the prosecution
you could say if you're innocent you
don't
fear being prosecuted that's fair but
it's really easy to counter in this
particular case because
if you believe that there will be
politically motivated
partisan political attacks you could
take the position that the next
administration will prosecute you
not because you committed crimes but as
political payback now
there's of course no evidence of that if
joe biden wins
and there are prosecutions of the trump
family it would be because there's
evidence that they committed crimes not
because of some personal vendetta by joe
biden
but for me the more important revelation
is about donald trump's desperation to
win
if don jr really believes
that there's a risk of prosecution if
joe biden wins in november
that must be at least somewhat in donald
trump's mind at least a little bit
and it would explain donald trump's
willingness
to do anything to win in november and
we've talked about this before
donald trump may genuinely believe that
he must win in november to avoid
prosecution
i actually don't think it's likely i
think the trump organization
will be gone after for financial crimes
and it won't touch
trump personally but if trump thinks
it's a possibility
he is like a cornered animal that's the
analogy we've been using and cornered
animals behave erratically that tells us
why
trump will use the post office and try
to suppress
vote by mail and try to close polling
places and contest the election results
and call it rigged and welcome foreign
interference because trump may see this
not just as fighting for his political
life and his reputation as he may see it
but as the way to keep himself out of
prison or at least out of a courtroom
for the rest of his life now
just imagine for the sake of following
this imagine if biden wins
and makes hillary clinton attorney
general and imagine that
she oversees prosecution of the trump
family
when it was trump in 2016 running on
lock her up
i don't deny that there would be
something interesting about that but
let's put it aside here and and not
really put the cart before the horse
the real takeaway is that a quarter
cornered animal will lash out in ways
that are incredibly dangerous and
violent
and that's what we have to expect over
the next 10 weeks here it is 10 weeks to
the day
today until november 3rd now my real
concern
is that trump won't lose in november and
that
yeah i can't exactly put my finger on it
but over the last two weeks
i've started to lean closer to thinking
a trump re-election is more likely than
it was a couple weeks ago
polling might be a part of it polling is
certainly tightened a little bit in late
june biden was averaging
plus 10 nationally now biden is
averaging
plus 7.5 so that's part of it
but there's something intangible that i
can't quite put my finger
on that has me more worried today about
a trump reelection
than i was two to three weeks ago let me
know what you think it might be
we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show instagram page
at david pakman show while you're there
follow me on instagram
david.pakman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it is great to welcome back to the
program today dr isaac bogash who's an
infectious disease physician and
scientist based out of the university of
toronto and toronto general hospital
uh always great to talk to you
nice to see you again so i guess just to
start with briefly
um we're seeing the u.s number of
coronavirus cases
down from their sort of second peak
still around 40 000 cases a day i know
you're in canada i don't know how
closely you're following the ins and
outs of case numbers here
but there's some skepticism about
whether these case numbers
can be trusted at this point given a lot
of different things that have gone on
with the data with testing pause due to
weather events
and so many other things my question to
you is
is there really a better metric to pay
attention to
at this point be it hospitalizations or
deaths or something else
in all fairness i look at a combination
of metrics i think the number of new
cases per day is very very helpful
but above and beyond that i look at
other metrics as well i look at the
seven day average i look at the number
of tests that are performed i look at
the
percentage of tests that are positive
out of the number of tests that are
performed
and i really think that when we sort of
combine all of those metrics and
more we really paint a more holistic
picture that gives us a better
understanding
of course if testing isn't being done
it's hard to know exactly
what the ground truth is but in all
fairness i think it's
by this point in time we sort of know in
most
regions how things are going and what
direction things are turning
either for better or for worse so one
specific question on testing and
positivity
sometimes we will see a situation where
it looks like
in a particular state cases have gone
down
and then when you look in a little more
detail you see
that tests are down 30 percent
and new cases are only down 10
which implies a higher positivity rate
and it suggests that it's because
you're doing less testing that cases
have gone down the counterpoint is well
you know if the testing goes down you're
probably only testing sicker people
so it makes sense that the positivity
rate would go up
it doesn't necessarily mean there are
actually more cases out there
is there any way to know for sure well
yes there is and the real answer is
getting
lots of disparate data sources together
in one place and really that is why it
is so
important to look at several metrics
rather than just relying
on a handful of metrics and then of
course watching the metrics through time
an individual day or even a few days
really does
nothing to us it's really important to
look at longer term trends seven day
trends and and beyond
uh and i think if we're starting to do
that and stop reacting to
you know terms like uptick and downtick
every time we see some variation in the
data we'll be in a much better place
there's going to be the expected
normal variations on a day-to-day basis
and even maybe on a bit of a longer term
basis
but if we look at weekly trends and look
at multiple data sources
i think we'll be in the right place and
really truly all of those combined
together give us
gives us a good impression i don't think
anyone following this is really looking
at
that you know one true metric that's
really going to provide all the answers
it's a it's a multitude of metrics so
let's talk about the next
three to four months um
some of the countries that did
successfully flatten their
curves are starting to see some more
cases
spain is one example that i've been
looking at and there are many others
in the united states when we first got
down to 20 000 cases a day
things just basically reopened and we
went all the way way back up to 75 now
we're back down to 40.
what is the best assessment now of what
was originally thought of in the may
projections to be
a discrete second wave which now is just
maybe going to be a kind of continuation
what is the timing looking like how bad
could it potentially get
it's interesting because we talk about
the second wave like it has some finite
definition
and in all fairness i don't think it
really matters whether or not this is a
spike in the first wave a plateau in the
first wave a distinct second wave
i think a lot of this is irrelevant in
the sense that number one you still have
a very susceptible population meaning
that
you know in most places the vast
majority of people have not
had this infection so are susceptible to
getting this infection
and number two if you don't have
controls in place to keep this infection
at bay
uh you're going to see widespread
transmission
so you know if we look in the crystal
ball a lot
there's you know it it we can predict
what's going to happen
uh if people are in indoor environments
in close proximity
for prolonged periods of time we know
that this is the perfect setup for
transmission now let's think about
what's going to happen
in the months ahead at least in the
northern parts of the united states
it's going to get cool we've got kids
going back to school
we've got many people going back to work
in person we've got cooler temperatures
that are driving us
inside we've got economies that are
opening and
all of those just put people together in
indoor environments for prolonged
periods of time
that is where this virus is transmitted
if we take steps to mitigate that
spread people apart put a mask on when
you go inside
limit the number of people in indoor
settings we can probably
do a decent job in mitigating the spread
but i still think we'll probably see a
rise in cases at least in the northern
part of the united states
and certainly in canada as we enter the
fall and winter months
so in terms of masks obviously
there's been a lot about masks over the
last many months
in particular there is disagreement i
guess we can say about
the degree to which masks prevent
transmission and whether they're really
to protect one from spreading versus to
protect one from catching or both
there's a very popular meme that's been
floating around which
assert you know it puts numbers to it
where it says both people wear a mask
it's like a one percent chance of
transmission
if one person wears a mask it mask it's
five percent if neither one does it's
fit or whatever right
yeah i'm sure those aren't the right
numbers but
are there any numbers or or specificity
to
the effect of masks and then of course
what type of mask i'm guessing is a
factor as well
right i think we can talk about this in
general principles and and
you know i certainly just full
disclosure mask
is probably my least favorite topic of
this epidemic or pandemic
interesting for whatever reason this was
like the hot button issue
this was politicized to such a degree
people have
very very strong opinions on on many
different sides of the
equation people are cherry-picking data
to suit their preconceived ideas
and it's really frustrating when you
really want to just take a
public health look at this an
epidemiologic look at it
a medical and scientific look at it it's
kind of frustrating and and quite
frankly it's frustrating because
people who should know better are are
still
i think speaking beyond the data or
still cherry picking data having said
that there are
many rational voices both in the lake
community and them and in the medical
scientific and public health community
and i commend those people because
anytime we talk about this for whatever
reason there seems to be a dog pile
effect
now let's get to the question so in
general
based on what we know now we can talk
about math
at an individual level and we can also
talk about masks at a population level
i think we can also talk about math in a
healthcare specific
area as well but in general at an
individual level if you
put a mask on and you're infected you're
just going to reduce the amount of virus
that you transmit to the environment
around you
seems to make sense pretty good idea now
does this pan
out at a population level um
it's interesting there's modeling
studies which
quite frankly you know i work in
epidemiology as well
and you know a lot of my career is based
on
working with modeling and and whatnot
i've got to say like
i should be the big supporter of models
i think models are helpful
but i don't think they really answer
definitively the questions that we want
to
answer they're helpful they're useful
but we have to take
a lot of the modeling data with a grain
of salt so
at an individual level great i think
it's it's a no-brainer
we've known this long before covet 19.
if you put on a mask you just
reduce the amount of virus you're going
to shed in the environment around you at
a population level
the waters get a bit murkier uh
will it really help at a population
level if there's
masking yeah you know what at the end of
the day if we sift through the data
it probably helps but i think it helps
to a much
smaller extent than what many people
might believe or might want to believe
but i'm not saying it doesn't help
i think it does and then you know how do
you take this data and translate into
policy
i think at the end of the day we also
know where this virus is transmitted
it's almost
well i shouldn't say exclusively but
it's truly an
indoor virus like there's just
remarkably few transmission
of this virus that are credible
that have been documented in outdoor
settings sure can happen in an outdoor
setting but it's just
not nearly as common as indoor setting
so if
we take our data that we have with mass
with the
total appreciation that this is
imperfect data with the total
appreciation that it's going to be
impossible to
you know at this point to have a perfect
randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled trial or whatever we
want to
design you know but if we take the
existing data that we have i think it's
very reasonable to translate that into
policy to say listen
if you're in an indoor setting you
should put on a mask
i think it's as simple as that outdoors
i'm i mean i i've seen
some of the narratives coming out of the
united states with people saying you
know i went for a 20k
jog and i had a mask on my whole time
and this didn't
didn't bother me one bit you know mazel
tov we're all very proud of you for
wearing a mask but like i don't think
you're at
risk of transmitting this infection if
you're on a 20k jogging you probably
don't need to wear a mat
i'd focus on indoor settings i think
master a great idea
taking the politics out of it we should
be putting on a mask when we go indoors
yeah i mean i i i've said this we don't
let's we'll move on after this but
here in boston now if you're just even
walking downtown if you don't have a
mask on
you know people can't kind of look at
you from the studies i've looked at it
really doesn't seem like that
is at all a high-risk scenario but if
people want to do it like you said mazel
tov you know look i am i'll do it i'll
do it in order to participate because i
don't want to be the person who's not
participating but it doesn't really seem
to be based too much in the science
i think you have a really good point
there and a lot of this
bleeds well out of science and medicine
and into more sociological or
socio-political conversation
i'm sitting here in toronto i cannot
comment i cannot emphasize
on what you're going through in the
united states in terms of the degree of
politicization
that this has had and if the mask might
also represent
a lot more than hey i'm
i'm here to keep you safe in case i'm
infected and i appreciate that there's a
lot more going on in the united states
with regards to that than there is in
canada
it might be a signal that i align with
this particular group or that i have
these particular beliefs
and in all fairness i'm not into shaming
and blaming people want to wear a mask
go for it wear a mask but like where i
would be more of a stickler about it
is in indoor settings i think it's
important that people put them on when
they go inside
i think that will actually have some
utility in preventing the transmission
of this infection
okay so vaccines multiple vaccine
candidates
on spec production of a number of them
so that if indeed we learn this one is a
go or that one is a go
doses will be available makes perfect
sense
russia claims to have a vaccine which um
has a number of questions around it uh
at this point
my thought has been the optimistic
scenario
is somewhere around october 15 there's
an announcement made that a vaccine
is safe and at least gives four or five
months of immunity
it starts to be rolled out slowly health
care workers
maybe by the end of the year 2021
high risk populations is that still the
optimistic scenario
where where are we on vaccines yeah i
mean the pace of vaccine development is
just staggering this is phenomenal
there's
uh about two dozen that are in human
clinical trials remember
we didn't know this infection existed
seven months ago
and now seven months in you've got just
over two dozen in human clinical trials
i think right now there's
six or seven that are in what's called
phase three human clinical studies
like that's amazing i mean that's that's
where you're enrolling
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people to answer the question
does it work and is it safe so you know
there's tremendous pace and of course we
know many of these vaccines are going to
fail
but there's so many that are in
development and even in advanced stages
of development that
i'm with you i i do share that
optimistic outlook that
we'll probably have some successful
trials
in before the end of 2020
i wouldn't be surprised if needles start
going in arms before the end of 2020.
hey i could be totally wrong i could be
way off and it could be
2021 and these might be a bust but the
looking at the data that we have
available to us it's pretty promising
it's not you know nothing of course is
guaranteed but i share that i share that
view
i also like that concept where uh many
governments or i guess in in in
partnership with the companies
just say you know what let's just mass
produce these vaccines
now we appreciate that we might be
tossing a billion dollars out the window
if it doesn't work
but the ones that do work we can already
start to roll out
vaccine programs like that's a really
smart idea if you've got money to burn
that's a great way to spend it because i
think at the end of the day
when you balance the economics uh loss
versus gained i think this will likely
side towards
a net gain i'm not a health economics
type of guy
but i i'm pretty sure that that's the
way the the tables will turn or at least
the
whatever the word you know what i'm
trying to say now when it starts to
become available
it takes a while before we really get
towards being able to say
we have ended the pandemic right i mean
it's when you took
my belief my understanding is with
something as contagious as coronavirus
about 70
immunity is required for herd 40 percent
of the u.s is not even interested in
getting the vaccine which is a totally
different story
but this once the vaccine rolls out it's
still going to be a while right
yeah yeah exactly i don't think this
pandemic is going to end with a bang but
more with the whimper right it's
probably going to peter out
uh as more and more people get
vaccinated or as more and more people
get this infection and then recover from
it and have
some degree of immunity for some period
of time
so it's probably going to peter out i
think the other thing that
it's not talked about a lot is even
though
we'll have access to this vaccine in
many high-income countries
this pandemic is still going to be
raging in many other parts of the world
especially in low-income countries
that sadly are you know might not have
the same access to the vaccine that that
you and i will have
uh and uh and i think there's going to
be a lot of individuals
a significant proportion of the globe
that will be suffering
disproportionately suffering
because of limited access to the vaccine
because many of the high-income
countries
are buying it all up and and snatching
it all up and
and you know i really hope i know that
there are programs i know the who's
looking into this and there are groups
looking into this to really have more
equitable
vaccine programs worldwide
uh but you know part of me is a little
bit skeptical as to
how successful those will be oh we're
going to go to a break on the podcast
and radio show with dr isaac bogash but
our full conversation
will be on the youtube channel the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about
them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so i have a few different absolutely
crazy things to catch you up on
uh relating to one of donald trump's
closest advisors kellyanne
conway kellyanne has announced that
she's going to be leaving the white
house at the end of the month meaning in
just a few days
because of a need to quote focus on the
family now if you're not aware
kellyanne conway has been just a
disgusting
trump sycophant for years but she
happens to be married to george conway
who is an anti-trump republican and who
in fact has become one of the loudest
anti-trump republican voices on the
internet and part of this anti-trump
republican coalition called the lincoln
project well
in the middle of all this their daughter
claudia conway
became an outspoken anti-trump
personality
online clearly things are really bad for
the family and so kellyanne conway has
now announced that she's leaving the
white house
george conway is leaving the lincoln
project and leaving twitter
and it seems that this clearly is the
right move for them as a family
and part of the constant dysfunction of
the trump white house
has just bled over and is ruining so
many people's lives
and uh clearly the decision made by the
conway parents must in part be because
of
the insanity that their children have
been pulled into
kellyanne conway putting out a statement
saying about her
and her husband that quote we disagree
about plenty
but we are united on what matters most
the kids
our four children are teens and tweens
starting a new academic year
in the middle school and high school
that will be conducted remotely from
home for at least a few months
as millions of parents nationwide know
kids doing school from home
requires a level of attention and
vigilance that is as unusual as these
times
this is completely my choice and my
voice in time
i will announce future plans for now and
for my beloved children
it will be less drama and more mama
their daughter claudia also tweeted over
the weekend that she was going to be
taking a break from twitter
and listen this all is a horrible
situation
but in the middle of this their
daughter in a now deleted video also
accused kellyanne conway of physical
abuse
and again that video has since been
deleted
there have been notable twitter
exchanges between mom and daughter for
example when kellyanne tweeted
about herman cain quote herman cain led
a remarkable life and will be missed
he loved his family the country and the
lord he triumphed in business
beat cancer and was a voice for freedom
god bless you and yours herman
her daughter claudia conway responded
yes it is sad but
wasn't your administration complicit in
his death
yikes so here's the bottom line
i don't i don't know if kellyanne conway
abused her daughter
uh i i don't know anything about that
this is clearly a family in struggle
it should be up to them to figure out
what's best for the family
i'm less interested in the gossip
element and more interested in the theme
which is that everything trump touches
turns to manure
how many lives and i'm not talking about
you know you can talk about
millions of lives have been ruined by
donald trump's presidency
in terms of financial repercussions or
the friends and relatives of the people
who died of coronavirus who didn't have
to i'm not talking about that
i'm just saying people who work for
trump
the people trump brings around him the
number of ruined lives
people arrested people fired people
becoming global laughing stocks
kellyanne conway is the 557th person to
leave the trump administration since the
beginning
trump's sister recorded has been
recorded recently saying horrible things
about
trump trump's niece wrote a devastating
book about him
melania is now reportedly recorded
saying horrible things about trump and
his own children which i'll talk about
next
we just need a normal presidency and a
normal president and as i tweeted a
couple of days ago and it seemed to
resonate with a lot of people
joe biden's presidency if we get one
would probably be one of the most boring
in a very long time
and that's perfectly fine with me now as
parents
it does seem the conways realize
that this public battle where they've
been on opposite sides of this
presidency has been terrible for their
family and their kids
that's good i guess it's better that
they recognize that now
instead of in another six months we
could say but it would have been far
better for them to recognize that
three and a half years ago let's now
talk about the melania revelations
so everything is just falling apart for
donald trump
not only did his niece write a
horrifying book about him
uh not only did his sister get caught
on leaked audio slamming him but now
there were reports that donald trump's
own wife melania trump the first lady
has been caught on tape making
disparaging comments
about both donald trump himself and his
children
the recording has been reportedly made
by stephanie winston
wolkov who's a former advisor to melania
and she's going to be putting out a book
in september called melania and me
the rise and fall of my friendship with
the first lady
now this is essentially gossip in a
sense
but it's gossip that goes to the same
story
trump doesn't have normal relationships
he's not a normal person
many of the people around him are around
him not just because they enjoy it but
for
who knows what kinds of other reasons
and much like
he ruins personal relationships he ruins
our relationship as a country with our
allies he's just ruining everything that
he touches
now the book will eventually have the
details that will be released in
september
presumably audio will also be released
but reportedly melania trump
in these recordings attacks ivanka trump
i guess melania really doesn't like
ivanka
and attacks donald trump himself and
attacks trump's other
adult children so this is really just a
reality show and and again as i said
just a few minutes ago in the last story
i look forward to and would welcome
gladly a
boring biden presidency and things just
being boring
for a while while donald trump is gone
now this is the same advisor to melania
by the way writing this book
that told melania remember when they
they came up with that be
best thing and it sounded just like a
grammatical mistake
uh this same advisor to melania who
reportedly
recorded melania disparaging trump and
his children
told melania that her b best slogan
sounded illiterate which it does i mean
it sounds illiterate
and it also sounds potentially
plagiarized which i'm actually less sure
about
if nothing else removing this
and putting the biden family in the
white house
it would just be a breath of fresh air
to just make this garbage stop
boring presidency i welcome and i can
tell you
boring won't be particularly good for my
business but who cares it'll be good for
the country
a scandal a day you know white knuckling
it with some new scandal every single
week it really is exhausting now to be
clear
biden being boring doesn't mean we stop
paying attention if biden wins
it doesn't mean we stop lobbying for
progressive change it just means the
process gets back to one of
being mildly connected to how modern
western democracies are supposed to
operate now of course
if biden is president fox news will find
scandals
they will fabricate scandals they will
concoct scandals if they need to
but they will be similar to obama wore a
tan suit
obama's choice of mustard was arrogant
or whatever
the other side to this is that there
will be
so much damage to clean up and most
likely
a biden presidency will be dealing with
at least six months
of trump continuing to be triggered
constantly by biden starting to undo the
damage trump has done
joe biden will still be dealing with a
pandemic nothing is fixed if biden
becomes president
it gives us the ball back to use that
analogy again and we can start to fix
things we'll still have the pandemic
the economic recovery from trump's
mishandling of the pandemic
is likely to take all of joe biden's
first term if he were to get one
but just for context and i know that
this is crazy to think back to
there were periods of time during barack
obama's presidency
where we didn't cover obama even for an
entire week
never mind every day like there were
times when the president just did their
job
and we talked about other things what
was going on in the senate
geopolitics and much else because there
wasn't constantly some fire to be
putting out
they seem like simpler times in some
ways now
back to the recordings of melania
slamming trump briefly
it really would be great if they were
released this week during the rnc just a
thought
trump would fly off the rails and i
would love to see it
let me know if anybody else is thinking
along the same lines
we have a voicemail number which you can
call anytime
the number is 2192 david p
here is a call from a guy who is very
happily voting trump take a listen
i am voting for president trump by the
way the requisite show playing in the
background it's always a it's a staple
of these phone calls
and no these will sit up there and lie
all you want to i am voting for
president
trump the best president i ever lived
god bless you and thank you
right so remember you can't talk a guy
out of that
in the 10 weeks we have left don't even
bother
we just have to get the vote out
remember that we've got a great bonus
show for you today
we will talk about uh reports of new
york city's demise being greatly
exaggerated we will talk about
differences in coverage of the
conventions on corporate media and
much much more make sure to get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at jointpakman.com or a patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video